leur dangereux le roller la regarde je
me suis pété pied mois en leur
temps ça tombe mal
c'est fou hein voilà voilà
voilà
encore un petit tour adopté un tout
petit ça m'amuse à man mais oui mais
monsieur il m'a dit que vous dérapez qui
vous arrive un problème à
baby 2 km mais lundi les rouleurs c'est
pas des rollers c'est des chaussures de
drag queen séoul est sorti
de soin de soi
la
grèce prend qu'il prenait j'arrive je
tiens y'a t'il d'accord à la bleue j'ai
pas mes chaussures bébé de jeu un
magicien venu au nom il fait froid on
alors tu perds frappe que je porte et
comme je le dis parce qu'on m'a piqué
mes chaussures d'appui région où il
avait un sac à dos noir il ya quelqu'un
il m'a pris deux fois par la pala par la
non à la pala je me suis ne peut pas
l'air
quand la non pas la pala - ballack à la
voilà
à les y pousser ouais mais poussés
jusqu'à là bas
vas-y we touch - parce que là doucement
ouais je veux bien oui
[Musique]
voilà la
merci au revoir
et qui se passe là qui va m'amener là
bas non pourquoi
bah oui mais moi aussi il faut que je
parte voilà
j'aime faire tomber c'est ça qui va
rêver on est pas mal pourquoi soit sympa
juste la croix du privé au lieu quoi
soit sympa tu y vas
[Musique]